I I really want to get your opinion on
something I don't know if if you know
what's happened in England
are you familiar in England news story
prince Andrew
had a great weekend I knew I knew about
that one well we did see that video
we're going to talk about that but
Scotland got their payback on the queen
I don't know if you heard about this
wait really
what happened
did you know where the queen ended up
dying yeah you know where where did she
die uh what's the name of the castle is
the Scottish castle that's her favorite
in Aberdeen Aberdeen thank you isn't it
it isn't a her favorite we made it nice
and comfy for her yeah and then when the
time was right are you Scottish yeah of
course
oh classic classic uh you know New York
white guy yeah oh uh Balmoral Castle
yeah that's right
um that was her favorite castle do you
know what Balmoral means in Gaelic oh no
die
that's what that means dude yeah you say
that but Edinburgh which is like the
most we don't consider that Scotland I
was about to say we don't get the most
like English adjacent part they were
beating the asses of anyone that even
said like [ __ ] the queen no because well
the funeral proceedings were happening
yesterday uh they and they like March
her [ __ ] casket through everywhere
which is crazy yeah so much is crazy
about the entire British Kingdom but
um the [ __ ] weird outfits this [ __ ]
but anyway we're gonna talk about the
Ottoman Empire outfits I mean
400 years no that [ __ ] was crazy too but
at least it's like flowy
[Laughter]
but yeah also they don't wear it now
they don't have like the royal guard in
turkey dressed up like that what are you
doing
what is the Vatican police yeah
um they are dripped up yeah you could
probably see that down the street in
[ __ ] nolita
some dude dressed like that just
grabbing a cobra whatever okay so you
were saying they're bringing the body
through so they're bringing the body
through and like some people are like
some people held up signs that said like
uh I think like not my Monarch or
whatever like and the monarchy and the
cops would just arrest them no they did
they literally like there was one kid
who said something like [ __ ] the queen
or [ __ ] the king or something and this
like Gammon [ __ ] summer ham looking
Scottish dude was like oh [ __ ] you like
he's beating the [ __ ] out of this like
teenager and then the cops like separate
them and immediately arrest the teenager
wow
not a real Scott so not a real Sky of
Scotland that's not a real I think
that's the most so insanely cut no no no
no I [ __ ] despise that [ __ ] what the
Scottish no I love the Scottish thank
you that's why I love the Scottish and I
love the Irish thank you but I [ __ ]
have so much disdain in my heart for a
[ __ ] who was like yeah no I love
the monarchy it's like bro what do you
mean they cucked you yeah
are you a big monarchy yeah
speak English Loser yeah
if I was you I wouldn't speak English I
was just refuse dude what was your
language before English and you even
know oh yeah do you even know German
yeah do you speak that yeah do you yeah
only when he's yelling at you only when
he's mad
I should stop speaking English too okay
but dude the worst is when Americans are
like oh how dare you disrespect the
queen what the [ __ ] wrong with you I
don't get this 1776 [ __ ] what is
this yeah
what is this it's the one time where I
was like yeah I feel American right now
can't be honest I don't get strong
feelings either way like yeah I'm 96
year old woman she died okay exactly
that's what happened it's not like they
[ __ ] brother in case she didn't die
yeah yeah yeah no exactly that's what
I'm saying it's like she won bro she won
yeah oh that's a good day no she won she
lived in 96. she lived a wonderful life
she like you know took money from the
poverty funds or whatever the [ __ ] you
know what I mean she did whatever the
[ __ ] she wanted and then sprinkled a
little bit of your money on like a
couple Charities so everyone was like oh
my gosh she's such a wonderful generous
yeah she won yeah she's a little bit to
kill Diana yeah that's really cool Diana
allegedly I think so why uh she was the
The Conspiracy is that she was [ __ ]
around with the Arms Dealer a brown boy
oh he was Muslim he was Muslim yeah you
can't imagine that yeah yeah
Temple when you were in Israel dude no I
didn't I missed that one you seriously
yeah oh it's fire dude you got to go how
is it how was it uh I mean it's it's
modest
one of the more modest things I mean the
stonework yeah basically my Limestone
yeah and just like a sick pergola in the
back for taking in a breeze
and
don't you gotta kill Princess Diana she
left your husband yeah everybody loved
her I remember there was a story where
she like saved kids that were drowning
she like [ __ ] jumped yeah she also
was like talking about AIDS at a time
when like everyone was like nah it's the
gay thing don't [ __ ] this up they're
killing all the gays like it's good land
mines
what you do with them she had that plan
moved she played after she played
tonight yeah wow that's cool she was
like we should take all the landmines
and put them in Ireland
that's a good place
we're having fun so she broke up with
her man I didn't know this
[Laughter]
like Princess Diana like they didn't
like her because she was like the
commoners princess right and she wasn't
like noble enough like high ranking
enough which means like she just wasn't
literally From A Distant cousin like he
wasn't inbred enough yeah yeah she was
not inbred enough yeah um and it showed
she was hot she was hot she could get it
oh my god
um and she was getting it bro yeah and
she was you could have taken that down
for sure
and you can go Raw on that thing too man
oh absolutely well yeah I'm winning in
that one
it's like yeah
sit down Boris I'll take it from here
yeah no a little little baby trap
Princess Diana dude that's great
um but
basically what I found out is if you
look up Princess Diana's summer I mean a
childhood home you will realize like oh
[ __ ] she's not a commoner at all she was
literally like multiple generations of
royalty as well just not as Royal as the
royal family so she's still what is it
[ __ ] Caked Up yeah yeah she was like
uh I think her dad was like a noble uh
wow but not high enough and I never knew
that and then I looked it up and her
summer home or her child at home in
England is like is a [ __ ] gigantic
castle son I thought she was like a
teacher or something yes dude they
[ __ ] make it seem like oh yeah you're
not you're not a part of like you're not
a descendant of like the Spanish King so
that means you're [ __ ] commoner
meanwhile the commoners living in the a
chateau wow yeah here's a question
that's a little dupe is anyone in the
royal family even English
no isn't that crazy like Elizabeth was
like Germany yeah and then her husband
was a Greek and and German so England
was run by a bunch of they're all bro
they're all like this like the thing is
first of all Elizabeth literally got
[ __ ] down by her cousin yeah those of
you who don't know yeah yeah like uh
Prince Edward right is his name I think
yeah he is her cousin they met when like
first cousin yeah no third cousin
however no no no no
third cousin for normal people makes
sense right right I'm super on board
with cousin [ __ ] yes okay yeah yeah
yeah you know let me just come right out
and say
third cousin for Royals yeah because of
so much inbreeding for centuries third
cousin for Royals is literally like
[ __ ] you know father-daughter type
[ __ ] like they are so uh intertwined
with one another that even if you're a
third cousin like you're still gonna
have some genetic disabilities and
medical conditions like the sausage
fingers that the current King has yeah
oh yeah yes it does tight bro yeah you
can't even [ __ ] write normally yeah
yeah it's weird yeah yeah he looks like
uh everything everywhere Everything at
Once
yeah the hot dog yeah he's hot dog
alternate route yeah so now okay wow
okay so then he becomes king for a short
time yeah he's probably gonna [ __ ]
he's not gonna survive that I don't
think his blood pressure is way too high
bro I mean yeah look at them [ __ ]
[Music]
I can't even take that off yeah I think
it's just stuck there his hands are
floating away and he's got a ring on it
still it's the best well it's like
blowing up from both angles
it's like it's like there's more on this
side and on this side like it's like so
committed you can't even pry that yeah
the jaws of life but like a tiny one
what is the argument for British people
who do love the monarchy like what would
people say what would they say if there
was an argument because I'm genuinely
curious I I don't understand the
connection yeah I don't understand
I think it's it's just patriotism in a
similar capacity yeah I was gonna say
it's like an extension of the flag yeah
like we got stars and bars and then they
have the flag and then this also
represents like they blew a 13 colony
lead right but yeah also like that was
that was kind of tight when they had it
for them yeah even though like you saw
none of it because you were a [ __ ]
peasant yeah yeah they think like oh
yeah we do eat yeah [ __ ] that was
awesome I did that it's like no
[ __ ] you didn't do that yeah
it's like Yankee fans they don't own the
team but [ __ ] we got them
exactly ah so the monarchy represents
the English Empire yes and there's still
pride in the Empire
and the people who are frustrated with
the monarchy feel like they're not
acknowledging what the cost of the
empire was which was what they had to do
to people atrocity genocide rape gotcha
now torture do we hold the royal family
accountable for oh yeah that even now
Elizabeth yeah everyone always like
everyone always has been talking about
like in American news about how like
Elizabeth oversaw the largest like
decolonialization operation over her
Reign and it's like bro it's not like
she was like oh yeah please go away like
it's fine she wasn't like yeah
congratulations for you know
decolonizing and having an independence
day no she would go there and they'd be
like yeah torture these [ __ ]
which they did they did it in Kenya in
Malaysia anytime there was like
especially if there was like a communist
Uprising or anything like that she was
there doing PR while the [ __ ] forces
were out there oh really wearing their
disrespectful ass outfits they were
shorts and [ __ ] I hate that but you're
really big into military uniforms and I
do I do love military uniforms I think
like if you're wearing if you're getting
don't buy a guy [ __ ] wearing shorts
like that's so disrespectful the
Chubby's Army is here God damn it I got
killed by God
you're the last thing that you see is
some [ __ ] sunburnt caps like red as
[ __ ] it's just yeah summer heat is like
yeah mate we have to do it to him
it's [ __ ] it's like fortnite dancing
on someone's corpse
you couldn't cover them shits up dude
what the [ __ ]